We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two David P. Hey
guys, just something really exciting, a reality
show producer reached out and is inviting
me to maybe be the next bachelor.
Take a listen,
David, this is rusty from Hollywood.
I'm here to offer your role as the next year's
bachelor.
Call me back.
Bye.
Yeah, of course.
You know the real mistake I think is that
the producers don't live in Hollywood.
The producers live elsewhere in nicer places.
Usually that Hollywood, uh, but maybe the
guy's office is in Hollywood.
Okay, thank you.
Yes, I would love to appear.
I would love to be the next bachelor.
Let's see if we can make it happen.
On today's bonus show was Martin Luther King
a Republican or a Democrat?
It is Martin Luther King day and we're going
to have a conversation about that.
And the answer is that it's complicated and
we will also talk about how Martin Luther
King's political views have been misstated
for personal gain by lots of different political
players and figures, all of that.
On the bonus show, we will also talk about
the European union wants all smartphones to
have a standard charging port.
And this is an issue that relates to many
different, um, uh, issues including, uh, accessibility
of technology.
There's a privacy component to it.
There's an intellectual property component
to it.
We're going to talk about that.
And in general, we're going to talk about
European regulation of businesses versus American
regulation of businesses.
And most, most of you probably can guess one
of the big distinctions there, which is that
in Europe they much more, uh, uh, proactively,
uh, regulating business.
And lastly, Donald Trump's border wall, even
without getting built, could be one of the
world's most costly.
What does that mean?
I will explain it on the bonus show.
Two ways to get access to the bonus show,
which we produce every single day for our
members and patrons.
Number one, go to join pacman.com sign up
for a membership.
It takes a minute, probably not even a minute.
If you're pretty good with computers, probably
30 seconds.
You can use the coupon code 2020 now to save
66% for a limited time.
You can also become a patron at patrion.com/david
Pakman show at the $5 a month or greater level,
$5 and 10 cents a month qualifies you $6 and
73 cents a month qualifies you.
It's just [inaudible]
five bucks a month or more and you'll get
instant access to the bonus show.
Sign up either way, both ways.
I'll speak to you on the bonus show in near
moment, the David Pakman show@davidpakman.com
[inaudible].